qu'il soit rouge blanc ou rosé qui
viennent de bourgogne d'alsace ou de
provence tous les vignobles français
sont représentés au salon du vin et de
la gastronomie de saint germain en laye
c'est une première participation pour
pascal pieds noirs venus de la vallée du
rhône qu'on essaye de faire des vins
rouges et blancs
un petit peu de rose et sur ses
méridionaux avec de la fraîcheur puisque
nous sommes situé à 500 mètres
d'altitude
pratiquement sur les contreforts alpins
pour accompagner la dégustation viticole
charcuterie fromage et gâteau des quatre
coins de l'hexagone sont à disposition
au bon plaisir des visiteurs
on a dû l'oms au delà copains on a aussi
des saucissons du jambon ça passe par le
cochon noir est aussi bien du sanglier
donc c'est des produits qui sont quand
même assez à ses fins et des produits
qui sont moins un peu poivrez mais ça
reste très léger très subtil je suis un
peu la diversité des produits
bon on pourrait encore avoir peut-être
un peu plus d'artisans
culinaire un peu peut-être un peu moins
de boissons mais ils sont tous charmant
on passe un bon moment
voir on n'a plus besoin de déjeuner
quand on rentre chez soi c'est une
taille réduite donc il ya un bien aussi
qui ait pas trop de monde parce qu'on a
le temps de discuter avec les
producteurs
cette 17e édition compte 42 exposants
invités par le lion's club de saint
germain en laye objectif récolter des
fonds pour des actions humanitaires
comme l'accompagnement de personnes
atteintes d'autisme ou d'alzheimer
il y a également des plantations
d'arbres au sénégal vers 160 me ce qui
permet de faire vivre des familles de
construire des écoles nous avons plus de
30 entre 2000 et 2500 visiteurs sont
venus durant le week-end l'association
ne souhaite pas communiquer la somme des
fonds récoltés